[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute machen wir ein
marokkanisches honig gebäck und sascha
weg hier das ist so lecker und er glaubt
kauf aber die marokkaner ist das ganz
typischer weise zusammen mit der hertha
so zum fastenbrechen auch wenn herr
wieder herzhaft und schmecke süß ist
machen wir das so und ich habe es auch
probieren ich find's super lecker also
probiert gerne mal aus ansonsten ist
stets und natürlich frei das auch
einfach so zu essen als süßspeise ich
zeige euch jetzt erstmal die zutaten für
den teig und dann geht es auch schon
weiter
wir benötigen mail außerdem geröstetem
sesam geschmolzene butter neutrales öl
etwas wasser außerdem essig und
orangenblüten wasser
des weiteren eine prise salz etwas
kurkuma sind gemeinden anis und
backpulver wo wir jetzt anfangen unseren
teig vorzubereiten müssen wir den sesam
malen und nimmt hier auf jeden fall
gerüstet zu sein falls er den nicht
bekommt dann könnt ihr ihn in einer
fettfreien pfanne anrösten und dann
kommt jetzt zu dem schritt den wir jetzt
machen nämlich das ganze malen also ich
glaube nicht dass jeder zu hause so
mahlberg hat und selbst total gruselig
anhört war über horrorfilm aber ich will
das nämlich jetzt nicht weil das hat ja
noch mal wirklich nicht jeder zu hause
aber was denke ich mal jeder hat ist so
ein mix aus und blender und da gebe ich
das jetzt rein und dann machen wir das
ungefähr ein bis zwei minuten an
so das war's auch schon jetzt haben wir
so eine art sesam mehr und der ganze
raum richtig nach see samen das trieb zu
angenehmen gerade und jetzt starten in
unserem teig dafür nehmen wir uns eine
große schüssel und geben zuallererst die
trockenen zutaten bereit
sesam und mehl habe ich schon drin und
jetzt gebe ich noch backpulver und die
gewürze rhein zu den gewürzen kann ich
sagen tauscht sie besser nicht aus denn
sind und an schließend sehr sehr wichtig
und der kurkuma sorgt für die schöne
farbe später
[Musik]
die trockenen zutaten sind jetzt in der
schüssel alles gut verrühren und in der
mitte ein bisschen platz machen für
unsere flüssigen zutaten hier gebe ich
erstmal öl und die flüssige butter rein
das wasser der spritzer essig und unser
orangenblüten wasser geben wir auch mit
hinein und auf das orangenblüten was
würde ich auf keinen fall verzichten
denn das gibt einfach schon richtig
schön orientalischen geschmack
[Musik]
den tag habe ich jetzt ungefähr fünf
minuten auf der arbeitsfläche geknetet
und der ist richtig schön geschmeidig
haben ein bisschen mehr da ist richtig
schön geschmeidig hat sich gut verbunden
und jetzt teilen wir ihnen einfach mal
durch 2 so jetzt müssen wir also wir
müssen nicht aber es wäre von vorteil
wenn wir den teig schon in so eine
quadratische form geben und dann in
frischhaltefolie einpacken und
anschließend muss der tag im kühlschrank
ruhen
am besten brücke den teig dann auch noch
flach dann können die nicht besser
durchziehen im kühlschrank und ganz
schön in der frischhaltefolie verpackt
und für die weiterverarbeitung muss er
nun aber wirklich eine stunde in den
kühlschrank das ist ganz wichtig und
dann geht es auch schon weiter so die
kühe zeit ist um und jetzt zeige ich
euch wie ihr die schiffe kers
traditionelle form da zeige ich euch
zwei varianten die eine ist für anfänger
und die andere für fortgeschrittene am
besten die arbeitsfläche mit etwas mehl
ausstreuen
dann nehmt ihr euch euer nudelholz und
heute so dünn wie möglich aus
so nachdem wir den teig so dünn wie
möglich ausgerollt haben geht's auch
schon ans zu schneiden
ein bisschen mehr ich benutze jetzt hier
so ein teil gretchen also eine gestellte
linie aber das braucht ähnlich unbedingt
also ihr könnt auch locker messer
benutzen und jetzt schneiden wir
deswegen habe ich auch gesagt macht am
besten quadratisch jetzt schneiden wir
nämlich den überschuss auch quadratisch
einmal ab hamm war so einmal hier den
überschuss abschneiden
so und ich zeige euch jetzt zuallererst
die fortgeschrittenen variante denn ganz
typische weg er ist ja dieses blumen
oder rosenmuster und das zeige ich euch
jetzt als allererstes es gibt viele
varianten das hinzukriegen ich zeige
euch jetzt liege ich für ein fach
empfinde und haben dazu muss noch ein
bisschen mehr kommen jetzt schneiden wir
nämlich den teich so in rechtecke und
ich mache das jetzt einfach nach
augenmaß aber ihr könnt euch vorstellen
dass sind so ungefähr
ja so 6 x 8 cm
so jetzt haben wir ganz lange breite
streifen ich rate euch geht jetzt so vor
ihr nehmt euch ein langen streifen und
dann schneidet ihr quasi sechs linien
den ersten haben wir hier schon den
zweiten dann müsst ihr aber nicht ganz
durchschneiden also schön hier also
nicht ganz am rand ansätzen schön viel
platz lassen ist der erste der zweite
345 und den 6 den zieht ihr wieder
komplett durch soll jetzt haben wir
dieses ausgangs muster so das sind jetzt
fünf streifen und wir nehmen uns jetzt
den ersten den mittleren und den letzten
so auf den zeigefinger und jetzt müssen
wir die beiden enden einmal hier als ob
wir den zeigefinger umschließen einmal
zusammendrücken
dann klebt das auch und jetzt nehmen wir
uns den so senkrecht legen uns sind hier
auf die arbeitsfläche und nehmen die
äußeren beiden die ersten beiden je nach
außen schauen klappen wir einmal drücken
dienten hier zusammen
dann kann man das hier noch ein bisschen
zurecht friemel und dann habt ihr auch
schon ein typisches kick hier muss dach
die vorbereiteten form gebe ich übrigens
immer gerne unter einem küchentuch ist
es auch immer gut wenn sie noch vor dem
frittieren ein wenig hohen so 10 15
minuten reichen da vollkommen aber ich
hab mich da noch gesagt ich zeige euch
jetzt die super super einfache form ich
habe mir schon mein zweiten teig
ausgerollt ich habe einen teil des tages
von falsches deutsch oder über habe ich
das mit dieser hosenform gemacht und die
hälfte von meinem zweiten tag dann zeige
ich euch jetzt so eine ganz andere form
so und dafür müsst ihr das ganze ein
wenig kleiner schneiden also ich mache
das jetzt einfach so nach gefühl
das sind dann rechtecke so und die
rechtecke die nehmt ihr euch jetzt
einfach und nehmt die zwei enden wie
gegenüberliegen und klappt die so
aufeinander und dann richtig schön feste
andrücken und dann habt ihr so eine form
okay ich glaube das hat jetzt ruhig ein
bisschen urteil sein könnt aber so im
prinzip also so müsste das dann aussehen
und beim frittieren werden der noch ein
ganz kleines stückchen größer
gerade dieses anfänger modell ist super
geeignet falls sie zb eure kinder oder
ihre kleinen geschwister mitmachen lässt
weil das kriegt er wirklich jeder hin
und wenn ihr dann noch so ein richtig
schönes gewähltes teil fährt habt dann
ist die form auch noch schöner
[Musik]
so habe ich mir jetzt meine stationen
vorbereitet ihr braucht zum einen einen
relativ hohen topf mit neutralem öl ich
habe hier sondern verwendet zum beispiel
könnt ihr auch abzunehmen
das erhitzen wir dann zweiter top mit
ganz viel honig und das dürft ihr auf
keinen fall auf kochen sonst schmeckt
nicht hinterher bitter also nur leicht
erwärmt
ihr könnt auch dabei ständig umrühren
damit da wirklich nichts passiert also
jetzt ist ja schon ziemlich ambitioniert
ihr wisst ja schon ein bisschen
flüssiger und wie gesagt auf keinen fall
auf kochen das dritte was sie benötigen
ist hier einmal so eine art sie und
darunter habe ich noch eine schüssel
gegeben damit wir später die fertigen
schiffe teams mit dem ruhm nicht
reingehen können und der überschüssige
wohl nicht einfach ablaufen kann was
auch wichtig ist ist nochmal gerösteter
sesam am besten schon mal bereit legen
weil das geben wir später auch darauf
dass es ganz typisch sobald an einem
holzstiel dann bläschen hochsteigen ist
das öl so weit also ist auf die richtige
temperatur gekommen und jetzt geht's los
ich mache das immer gerne so wenn ich
etwas irritiert was kommt man mir auch
sehr selten vor muss ich sagen dann
nehme ich immer gerne erstmal ein
exemplar tester das einmal komplett
durch wenn ich das gefühl gehabt wie
lange das ganze dauert dann kann ich
schon in einem schwung mädel reintun so
vorsichtig rein
sobald das ganze dann schön gold frauen
ist nehmt jetzt einmal aus dem topf
lastet gut abtropfen und dann rein in
das innen das heißt honig den halten wo
mich genau den honig und darf das darin
gerne minute schwimmen jetzt wo es raus
und jetzt kommt auch ein sehr wichtiger
part nämlich unser saison also richtig
schön hier mit sesam streuen
stefan bis hin zu viel aber wir haben ja
gesagt wir testen den ersten und jetzt
dass wir es einfach abtropfen und ich
zeige euch schon die nächste fuhre
[Musik]
und das war es auch schon so schnell
gehen kia und die schmecken unglaublich
lecker ich rate euch lasst sie
mindestens eine minute im honig wenn
nicht sogar zwei minuten denn umso
leckerer werden sie und was ich wirklich
bemerkenswert finde wir haben sie
frittiert und daneben in honig getunkt
und trotzdem schmeckt der teig so
richtig möhre und ihr müsst es unbedingt
mal austesten ich freue mich wenn ihr
mich über instagram mit dem hashtag ekis
kitchen markiert damit ich mir eure
leckeren fotos auch anschauen kann
in der infobox stehen alle genauen
mengenangaben wie immer ansonsten sage
ich abonniert beiden kanal damit wir uns
beim nächsten mal auch wiedersehen
tschüs
du hast mir erinnerung gewicht das habe
ich mal für das kind ist und jetzt hast
du das einfach
tränenüberströmt fertig ist so gepackt
lügenbaron
[Musik]